sa dernière ligne droite on est à moins
de trois semaines du défilé
salut les gains pour leur stage à la
loupe et inquiète on vient de commencer
sa grand-mère du maroc j'ai toujours
rêvé de visiter les pyramides de la
villa
lakers a
donc des connards
un petit problème avec votre titre de
séjour vous avez nous suivre gentiment
ah non mais moi je vais nulle part où
aller se taper la police on fait aussi
des papiers faut que je rentre j'ai
besoin aujourd'hui maya tu comprends pas
la non-expulsion demain première je suis
là elle utilise dans ses sirupeux savoir
sa famille peut vraiment avec et du
caractère de battant et autres sa
moustache
comment pour aller en ville je me casse
le maire de taxi pas de bus pas non plus
dehors mais vous avez battu la tête ou
quoi toi batman tas perdu robin 1 cuil
et toi t'es cool on n'en a rien à [ __ ]
de ta famille mange
j'ai pas fait mais bon c'est bon pour
tout le pays mais s'y prend mal
je trouve une solution pour entrer dans
moins de deux semaines c'est la vie des
personnages
montant de eur
exactement comme paris
pourquoi tout rentrait à paris ont tous
pris puisque ma vie est là-bas
mais enfin trouver une vraie solution
pour que tu rentres en france ouais tu
prends trois fois tu fais un voeu watts